for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy in
this video series i will be talking
about ketone bodies and before i can get
into any sort of details i should answer
the question what our ketone bodies but
before I can get into that I want to
backtrack a little bit and talk about
something that I've already talked about
up here to the left you'll see that this
is a fatty acid here okay and previously
I've talked about how fatty acids can be
broken down for energy specifically
they're broken down into a bunch of
acetylcholine molecules and the process
by which we can convert a fatty acid
into a bunch of acetylcholine molecules
is called beta oxidation I have a video
series on that you should check it out
if you haven't already and in that
process
we're basically metabolizing fatty acids
for energy in beta oxidation we get a
bunch of fadh2s
we also get nadh --is and of course
plenty of acetyl COAS and the acetyl co
waves can follow through through the TCA
cycle and when they go through the TCA
cycle they they give us some nadh --is
write some more nadh is some fadh2s and
some GTP's again all value to energy now
why am i talking about this well the
reason why is these acetyl COAS
when they're made they really want to go
through the TCA cycle but what can
happen is that the TCA cycle can give
backed up and if that happens the acetyl
co ways will build up right we'll have a
bunch of acetyl co a is kind of hanging
around the issue is that acetyl co a
does really like to hang around and so
it's going to be converted into
something else okay and so what will
happen is that the acetylcholine
molecules will undergo a process called
ketone body synthesis which makes the
ketone bodies it's also known as
ketogenesis okay and that will basically
take these as edokko ways and turn them
into these three molecules that you see
here this one this one and this one
these are the ketone bodies the one to
the far left here
is acetone the one in the middle
acetoacetate and the one on the right
here is d beta-hydroxybutyrate and so
these are the ketone bodies ketone
bodies hmm okay well ketone looks
basically like acetone right it's a
carbonyl with two R groups on either
side and they all kind of have that
except D beta hydroxy butyrate has a
carboxylic acid but the point is they
have carbonyl groups okay actually the
point is that these three are to be
ketone bodies and that's what you should
know okay so I've answered that first
question what are the ketone bodies
these three guys now during ketone body
synthesis or ketogenesis these three are
made now acetone is made to a lesser
extent than as you don't last a and D
beta hydroxy butyrate they're made to a
greater extent okay and what happens is
that the acetone that is made a lot of
it just ends up being exhaled okay um
whereas the acetoacetate and D beta
hydroxy butyrate they are transported in
the blood to extra hepatic tissues okay
why is that well why would that be
what's their purpose or function what
they do is they basically provide energy
for extra hepatic tissues at this point
you're probably wondering what the heck
is extra hepatic extra hepatic hepatic
refers to liver that part refers to
liver extra sort of implies basically
things other than the liver
all right so other than the liver so
basically the tissues outside the liver
tissues other than the liver okay
these are not used by the liver for
energy right these ketone bodies are
used for energy by other tissues some
examples I've got actually listed here
skeletal muscle cardiac muscle kidney
cells and the brain now I got a little
asterisk next to the brain and the
reason why is that the brain prefers to
use glucose for energy pretty much all
the time
but it will adapt to using ketone bodies
which I will abbreviate is KB it will
adapt to using ketone bodies during
starvation okay we'll talk a little bit
more about that later so now the
question is where they made well if
they're transported in the blood to
extra fatty tissues maybe I've already
given it away here with with hepatic
they're made in the liver specifically
in the liver mitochondria okay and that
should make sense given what we've
already talked about so far right we
mentioned beta oxidation and the TCA
cycle those both happen in the
mitochondrial matrix okay so this is all
happening in the mitochondrial matrix
what happens is that the TCA cycle is
backed up the acetyl co ways will go
through ketone body synthesis to make
these ketone bodies and these ketone
bodies here can be transported in the
blood to tissues outside of the liver
and those tissues can use these ketone
bodies for energy okay so now the
question is how are they made well
that's something we'll see in the next
video I hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying